assalamualaikum brothers and sisters he
did a DNA test mother and father
Jewish bloodline accepted Islam Amazing
Story coming up he wants to give some
advice here for those who are searching
purpose haven't found purpose they've
heard some negative things about Islam
whatever the case and we just had the
most famous man in the world
most Googles just saved Islam he did his
research you could do your research what
advice would you give from yakub
um so for any of you guys who are
searching trying to find meaning in
their life trying or if they've heard
about Islam and they don't really know
if this sounds right for them if it
sounds like it might it might be
restricting them or or that it's it's
harsh or something like that just do
your research real research and I'm not
talking about research from secular
people from people trying to give you
the answers you want no find your own
answers find the answers that people
don't want you to hear and read the real
sources get right to the get right to
the facts read the Quran for yourself
read the Hadith read what the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said for
himself
don't be one of those who just follows
in the footsteps of those other people
who are telling you don't don't go don't
go away from you know enjoying this life
that we have when you know that there
are things in that life that is toxic
those things that are drawing you away
from your your inner truth your inner
self you know the the one that we call
it the fitra right the natural
disposition don't run away from your
federal
try to find it again and if you're
Jewish
I was Jewish I grew up Jewish and I can
only tell you that Islam
is what Judaism was in the time of Moses
and you would only truly know the truth
if you read if you learn not not just
what the Torah says but also what we say
compare contrast and no we're not that
far off and you might just find what
you're looking for Wow that is deep
we've got this amazing story with this
amazing brother yakub here future
inshallah Deen Center we're outside
filming the D show we got to get the D
show inside of Dean Center subscribe
right now so you don't miss this show
when it comes out and support us so we
can go ahead and make this a reality
peace be with you assalamualaikum we
need to do this for the future of our
children the future of our great country
the future of mankind this is your
brother and I've got a very important
message alhamdulillah our brother Eddie
is setting up the dean Center not just
the dean show but the dean Center a full
dawa Academy a Masjid a dawa Center in
America the first of its type the a
groundbreaking project and I want
everybody as I'm supporting it I want
everybody to support it so we can take
the dawah to the next level we need the
dean Center please support it
[Music]